so i've got a vector field here v of x y
where the first component of the output
is just x times y and the second
component is y squared minus x squared
and the picture of this vector field is
here
this is what that vector field looks
like and what i'd like to do is compute
and interpret the divergence of v
so
the divergence
of v
as a function of x and y
and in the last couple videos i
explained that the formula for this and
hopefully it's more than just just a
formula but something you have an
intuition for is the partial derivative
of p with respect to x and by p i mean
that first component so if you're
thinking about this as
being p of x
y
and q of x y
q x y so i could use any letters right
and p and q are common but the upshot is
it's the partial derivative partial
derivative of the first component with
respect to the first variable
plus
the partial derivative
of that second component with respect to
that second variable y
and as we actually plug this in and
start computing the partial derivative
of p with respect to x of this guy with
respect to x x looks like a variable y
looks like a constant the derivative is
y that constant
and then the partial derivative of q
that second component with respect to y
we look here
y squared looks like a variable and its
derivative is 2 times y
2 times y and then x just looks like a
constant so nothing happens there so on
the whole the divergence evidently just
just depends on the y value it's 3 times
y
so what that should mean is if we look
for example let's say we look at all
points where y equals zero we'd expect
the divergence to be zero that that
fluid neither goes towards nor away from
each point so y equals zero corresponds
with this x-axis of points so at a given
point here evidently it's the case that
the fluid kind of flowing in from above
is balanced out by how much fluid flows
away from it here and wherever you look
i mean here it's kind of only flowing in
by a little bit and i guess it's flowing
out just by that same amount and that
all cancels out
whereas you know let's say we take a
look at y equals
i don't know like three so in this case
the divergence should equal nine so we'd
expect there to be positive divergence
when y is positive so if we go up and y
is equal to one
two three and if we look at a point i
don't know let's say around here and we
kind of consider the region around it
you can kind of see how the vectors
leaving it seem to be bigger so the the
fluid kind of flowing out of this region
is pretty rapid whereas the fluid
flowing into it is less rapid so on the
whole in a region around this point the
fluid i guess is going away and you know
you look anywhere where y is positive
and if you kind of look around here the
same is true where fluid does flow into
it it seems but the the vectors kind of
going out of this region are larger so
you'd expect on the whole for things to
diverge away from that point
and um
in contrast you know if you look at
something where y is negative let's say
it was y
is equal to negative and negative four
it doesn't have to be 3 there so that
would be a divergence of negative 12 so
you'd expect things to definitely be
converging towards your your specific
points so you go down to you know
i guess i said y equals negative 4 but
really i'm thinking of anything where y
is negative and let's say we take a look
at like this point here
fluid flowing into it seems to be
according to large vectors so it's
flowing into it pretty quickly here but
when it's flowing out of it it's less
large it's flowing out of it just kind
of in a lackadaisical way
so it kind of makes sense just looking
at the picture that divergence tends to
be negative when y is uh when y is
negative and what's surprising what i
wouldn't have been able to tell just
looking at the picture is that the
divergence only depends on the y value
that um that once you compute everything
it's only dependent on the y value here
and that as you go kind of uh left and
right on the on the diagram there if i
go up as we look uh left and right the
value of the divergence doesn't change
that's kind of surprising it makes a
little bit of sense you know you don't
see any notable reason that the
divergence here should be any different
than here but i wouldn't have known that
they're exactly the same